what he was tweeting that it might be
another cara khan but i say that and
he's swapped it straight away with the
queen's pawn opening um against because
he got in a bit of trouble in niche with
the white pieces yesterday when he
played the king's pawn moves so this is
why he's going for something
different and we already see a bit of an
unorthodox move there with the white
knight coming in front of the queen
because that blocks the bishop in it
blocks the queen in so it's a it's it's
a little bit strange that move
it definitely is a little bit strange
but it does have a purpose and the
purpose is simply you know if white is
allowed to they are going to put a pawn
another pawn in the center the e pawn
it's going to march two squares forward
and maybe the game will develop into
something a bit more um similar to
another opening that we kind of call the
modern or the perk well actually i was
watching a video a howl's how-to video
yesterday uh called opening traps and i
think actually i remember it was
something about putting the knight
in that place david okay that somehow
was an opening trap possibly i think in
a slightly different opening but yeah
sometimes putting
your knights on squares that do block in
your pieces it can end very badly so
here i don't think that's the case but
um yeah bit of a surprise for me
actually this next move yeah but have
you not played this yourself i have and
i had lost absolutely every single game
i played i did not like it it was too
passive for me and uh yeah
i had to make some changes so i'm very
curious to see what anish has uh well
brought to this particular variation
because
i felt very uncomfortable here with the
white pieces remember one game norwegian
league twenty yeah you don't need to go
into that
bad memories it is bad memories because
i lost every single game that weekend so
simon what do you think of this last
move uh i know you're a big big
supporter of pushing harry the h pawn
when your opponents kind of created this
formation arian's done basically a
mirror image of the a pawn yeah it's
always nearly always a good idea when
your opponent goes to fianchetto to try
and attack that structure but i think
kind of what's more interesting is the
approach that anish has taken to this
game
he's clearly going for a non-theoretical
opening which i think is a little bit of
a surprise because
we would assume that his openings are
probably better than um his second
because you know so why go for an
opening which is really not that
theoretical and what i mean by that an
opening where you don't really have to
memorize the move so much it's more
about uh just play this is more your
style david i'd say this is more like
you don't have to memorize the moves
it's not that important you just got to
know where the pieces go and planning is
so much more important
because it's not strictly like the tempo
of the game is not critical as such so
that's quite interesting i think um i i
didn't expect that from anish to go for
that style of play yeah i'm very
surprised as well because one of his
biggest weapons especially with white uh
they are his openings a nation he's
basically saying no
i don't really worry i'm not really kind
of fussed about trying to get an
advantage i'm just getting a position
and he's trying to keep all the pawns
all the pieces on the board um no
exchanges yet and we might well see uh
terry just think a bit longer he's the
first one to try and pause now and come
up with a plan as simon mentioned it's
just about choosing where the pieces go
it's not completely clear there's just
so much choice for black black slight
square bishop black's knight both asleep
they can come out now but where do you
put them what's the long-term goal in
the middle game it's those types of
questions it's not about surviving the
opening anymore so uh interesting
strategic choice maybe anish just trying
to get in tarry's head
bit of a surprise and he's the first one
to launch that surprise
which is normally a good thing yeah
definitely but i still i don't approve
of this choice by any just because i've
got such bad memories with it but you
know it's you know it's not it's not
entirely clear for black but it's also
in my experience not entirely clear for
white either because there are no
natural pawn breaks yes you could
perhaps push the c pawn forward but then
you concede some squares and as we know
in chess squares are currency you know
the more squares you give the more
options you give to your opponent so for
example okay
i just put this bishop here just as an
example but it's actually uh played in
the game very natural move black's
bishop now improved and uh just to show
your point of anchor on the board if
white ever pushes this pawn forward
which is actually quite a common idea
from the queen's gambit from a lot of a
lot of other queens pawn openings just
to challenge black stronghold then the
square you give away is this one it's an
eternal outpost for black and black can
very easily occupy that square in
white's half of the wood with his knight
later on and likewise for black um in
the current position if black for
example ever does the same and pushes
this pawn forward then he gives away uh
the square next door and white controls
this square for eternity
so uh yeah it's a bit of a weird
standoff i'm expecting to see this
bishop move yeah there we go just to get
the white king castled
and a lot of maneuvering but is that a
golden chest to to control all the
squares on the board all 64 squares then
you get well you can't quite control all
64 squares can you
maybe
it is i think technically legal to kind
of have uh make eight queens on the
board
you could control all the all the lines
or the files or the ranks i wonder if
it's been a game between two grand
masters where every single square has
been controlled that is a that's quite a
weird question
has there ever been a grand master game
where one grand master has controlled
every single square you know i mean uh
in a c in a serious game unlikely
maybe when there's a big imbalance
between strengths and very strong play
against a very
can you guys if you played me could you
can you imagine a way to control all the
squares on the board is there i think
you'd have to queen a lot of pawns so if
you can queen your pawns get more queens
and you could uh you could do it that
way probably so but then but then the
opponent would also control some squares
too just take all their pieces yeah
just
just eliminate it just don't bother just
take them off and then you'll get there
eventually won't you there's been some
yeah i mean i've seen some of these
challenges before where you know you
have to checkmate with a certain pawn
that you write down before the game and
things like this which is like you do
that successfully simon yeah i've done
that done that once or twice on the
stream but it's it's quite fun you know
to sort of you know give little
challenges it's like a game of pool or
billiards where you call it when you
have to name where you're gonna yeah put
the black ball or yeah yeah a bit
similar to that i mean that's a little
bit easier maybe than naming which pawns
you want to check mate
you know it wasn't quite squares but i
know that uh former world champion bobby
fischer
used to do this to people oh you know
he'll be playing in tournaments and he'd
be like i'm the youngest here but you're
you're the oldest you're going to lose
to me
[Laughter]
i'm playing in a team which is called
the drunken knights chess club
pretty good name i think it was quite a
famous team in london but we have one
restaurant in my home village yeah and
as well and uh
drinking
well equally strong the drinking game
was very strong
the chess was okay but we'd uh we'd give
ourselves challenges before the match so
we'd actually play in a pub
and we give ourselves little challenges
like you know you can't move the queen
and the person who doesn't move the
queen the longest you still have to win
the game you know we'd all put a little
bit of money in the pot and uh do that
so it's a lot of fun it was a lot of fun
doing this and uh playing in a pub was
just weird though i mean remember we're
playing there and we're playing a very
strong team
and so this guy just opened the door
chess
why you like doing playing chess
stupid game
and he walked out so it's like yeah i
remember the motto it was uh wasn't it a
drinking club with a chest problem that
was it yeah yeah yeah yeah
it was great but it was so friendly and
you know that's that's shows the other
side to chester you don't you know it's
not all about professionals playing you
can enjoy it with your friends in a nice
environment and it can be a very social
game very social game so yeah yeah i
mean there's no reason why it has to be
so quiet you know i mean and noi they
i think they might still have it but
they used to have a
this kind of national nm
national championship in a coffee chass
they called it and the whole point was
that you should be as social as you
liked you could talk to your opponent
you could troll your opponent you could
drink and it was it was really different
i mean i played in it once and i had a
great time but it was so strange to
suddenly hear my opponent go yeah you're
losing aren't you
silence please
all right well we do have a few moves
yeah the first the first pieces have
left the board um so we did just see a
night trade and
i hesitate to call it the first critical
moment of the game but a bit of a timid
decision from tarry
just to go back and uh okay white's king
is now castled but just to rewind a
couple of moves here white played knight
takes knight and i think if terry was
really really feeling
aggressive he might have played pawn
takes night this is maybe my first
instinct at least because when the white
knight now kicked away from its ideal
post when it retreats black can start
chipping away at the white center
look at these bishops it's all about the
tension here maybe white is okay but the
black bishop definitely putting pressure
on instead of taking that risk um it is
a bit of a risk since white uh now has
targets these double pawns aren't great
um instead of this irene decided okay
not gonna imbalance the pawn structure
he takes with his bishop and after white
castles he goes for the same plan but
maybe less effective and uh remember now
this is eternally a
outpost for white's pieces watch out for
a white bishop or maybe even a white
knight later on in the game landing on
this square and there's tension on this
diagonal as mentioned right now white
can't play pawn takes pawn because his
bishop would be hanging
along the diagonal so it's a bit of a
lock and key situation uh black can
choose when to unlock
this diagonal and trade off a set of
pawns in the meantime it's not 100 clear
what white does first i mean this
reminds me i think it was yesterday was
saying uh uh anish wrote a wrote about
this game in new and chess magazine and
he was saying that the bishop that's
defended fee and chateaud so we can
highlight that one in front of the king
is always a little bit better than the
bishop on the other side of the board
which is not defended and i think that's
the case here uh white can't move the
pawn in the center
but somehow black blank's got a little
bit better protection there
so that's i guess one advantage black
has in this position this diagonal but i
agree that there's a lot of weakened
squares as well that white has maybe
control of yeah maybe this one um it's
interesting that that's kind of uh
anisha's rule right but then he's the
one with the worst bishop in this
scenario so maybe he's feeling
uncomfortable he wants to have black's
bishop and
with that uh kind of discomfort that
he's feeling um he pushes a pawn forward
oh that's an ugly move blocking in his
own bishop but it was just the tension
along this diagonal i think he was a bit
too uh worried about so
yeah it's ugly putting a pawn on this
square but it's also very solid you've
kind of locked down everything you're
protecting your pawn in the center twice
so uh pros and cons there maybe it's
also saying to black hair you can't put
your knight where you want to put it or
turn the c6 square because maybe after
that move you can just simply go pawn
takes pawn
get greedy yeah white can grab a pawn
because now this diagonal is blocked
the black
the white bishop at least is protected
so maybe a small kind of hint of a
threat on the board pawn takes pawn i'm
expecting aaron just to defend that
maybe um with his queen i'm not sure
which square this one this one just to
keep an eye on his pawn here
yeah early early days but uh his
position do we prefer
seems very equal to me at the moment i i
mean i would say it's it's it's too
early to decide is
anish has just you know gone into this
position with this kind of uh middle
game in mind i would have thought you
know very
boring
am i allowed to say that uh maneuvering
i'd say i mean it's not fireworks yet
but it will it will become more more
interesting simon
you're three three a.m in the morning
and i've shaken you awake and i say you
have to choose white or black would you
want to choose
black okay i got black only because
i like playing with more space
but three o'clock in the morning you're
shaking me awake
now let me just think about that i know
is your husband watching
[Laughter]
let's move on quickly
i mean i i was going to say black
because it feels like black has a little
bit more space
just a little bit
but i mean there's not much in it here's
another kind of angle for the same
question in a way but whose style do you
think it suits more giri or tarry this
type of position i'd imagine giri right
i mean because
anish likes quite safe safe positions i
mean generally i mean he can play what
people forget that niche can play
extremely aggressive as well i mean he
had this reputation of being a draw
master but that was a bit unfair in in a
lot of respects but actually recent
years yeah he's so excited now but i i
think ariane prefers the dynamic games
so it's more
that's not this is maybe not what black
would really want but you're equal so
you can't complain too much either i
have to say i i still despite playing
this type of opening with the white
pieces i'm
so traumatized by those results um
actually like sure you're only
traumatized by that
i mentioned okay
um
yeah so
i was gonna say that i really like
black's position just because it's
easier to play i mean i really don't see
what white's plan is also you mentioned
uh well simon mentioned earlier the karo
khan and this pawn structure could
easily arise from the karo khan defense
it started as a queen's pawn opening uh
but this type of position
yeah has massive similarities especially
in terms of pawn structure um to those
positions that i think you've got some
experience in ivanka and i know that
ariane terry playing caracan yesterday
against danish he's got experience in
this type of pawn structure as well uh
meanwhile white's bishop we mentioned he
blocked in his own bishop a bit of an
ugly move now it's found a better
diagonal
and bishop bishop's on the rim
are they okay no they're not there okay
because the bishop is a long-range piece
they can even
be on their starting squares and be
incredible
so it's just the knights that need to be
really in the center
or they need to have a specific purpose
in mind if they're going to be placed in
some unusual square
the one thing you don't want with your
bishops though you don't want to stare
at your own pawns
so you want an open diagonal to look at
you or you want to target one of your
opponent's pawns or pieces or or you
want to pin
your opponent's knight maybe
that's another kind of dream a very
sensible move then yeah
yeah i mean with bishops you're always
looking to and this is a boring a soviet
phrase you know lengthen the diagonal
and you even do this when your opponent
has a put a pawn in that your own
bishop's way you try to break that that
line that diagonal apart and uh well uh
ariane playing very sensibly uh
developing the queen
i mean these kind of games that they are
much more i i i did say the word boring
but you can learn a lot more i think
from games like this than from big
tactical battles because when you're
watching uh you know a big tactical
battle it's literally you have to just
find a tactic find a tactic but seeing
how top players maneuver uh their pieces
um is i think
much a much more interesting
way to improve your positional chess
because you know
they move differently to most other
players so why are they playing those
moves what are their ideas
and anisha's idea of moving the pawn and
the bishop i wouldn't have seen that i
wouldn't have played that so i think
they're much better to learn from these
types of uh games uh for for maneuvering
battles so they do have that benefit
it's like you can test your wits and
just see how they kind of
piece their pieces together piece their
pieces i didn't mean to say that but
that's what came out
but anyway it's how they harmonize
together and how he will try to find a
point that he can put arya antari or ari
antari to anish they will try to put
their opponents under pressure
and uh yeah this is very tense uh battle
so far
and whilst the players are deep in
thoughts well we do have two
competitions i'm super excited about
this we have a quiz of the day where
we're asking what is your goal in chess
and we also have a selfie competition to
win the good stuff as anish called it a
signed cushion and uh new in chess
magazine and honey bees she's been very
smart here she's actually combined her
answer
a selfie
and her goal and she says that her goal
is to promote her chest opening called
the honeybee the bees opening uh and uh
a female and american invented opening
the bee defense bee defense yes oh
that's a cool name yep that is a cool
goal as well to have your own opening uh
look forward to seeing what the bee
defense is and ryan baker
i think is a doctor who fan but uh says
riversong and daddy love our
commentators and the great chess and uh
river song of course is the
she the
one of the
no i had no idea the the
people who come accompany the time
uh no no amy pond was the one i have no
idea what's going on at the moment
riversong was the daughter of amy pond
that's no spoilers but yes yeah yeah
yeah yeah she was uh she was a love
interest for one of the doctors on the
show yes oh doctor who okay yeah that's
a great name ryan and thank you for
watching
and um okay meanwhile anish tries to get
rid of black's strong bishop in the
center of the board
all right yeah black bishop has a choice
simon
are you a bishop or nightman which piece
is black's bishop going to capture
has a choice of two i mean it obviously
depends on the situation and i think
generally you'd take the bishop um
i mean i'm looking at ideas of taking
the knight and then lunging with the
pawn in the center of the ball but i
can't do that at the moment and i've
been very careful making any committal
decisions so
i probably take the bishop or maybe i
don't even need to take the bishop maybe
i can play something else i i again
these are the kind of position i have to
admit i sometimes struggle with because
it's it's just finding a plan and if
you're not used to these
positions it's like okay
it's much harder to automatically move
your pieces to good squares i mean maybe
i put a rook in the middle of the board
if i wasn't sure what to do maybe i put
that rook even behind the e pawn the
other one in the middle this is the kind
of things i'd be thinking of just
waiting uh for something to happen but
it's uh it's not easy to know for me to
write plans here for either side yeah so
the reason you want to put your rook
here is as you mentioned actually is to
explode open the center pushing this
pawn two squares forward there's two
ways to play this either for example you
trade off a bishop for a night and then
you say okay i'm the only one with a
knight now so i'm just going to block up
the center for example you move your
rook across next move you just push your
pawn you just sit and lock things down
oh he's done okay he's done exactly this
actually um next move as well as pushing
his pawn one square he could push it two
squares for example i'm not even sure
what white does here to be honest i'm
assuming he moves one of his rooks
but then the pawn pushers and this
bishop is actually going to become the
key piece um after a trade of pawns here
black is doing fantastically well
hitting the bishop hitting the queen and
actually targets as well
in the white camp
so big i think strategic threats i need
to push this pawn two squares but aryan
has the choice if he feels he's not
ready uh for example if white makes a
move if he feels he's not ready to push
the pawn two squares and commit open
things up for the white bishops then he
can just sit and even this structure
from my experience with the karakan and
similar openings this is pretty decent
for black as well because actually
other than a potential kingside attack
for white which i know simon would
definitely go for other than this white
lacks a plan so
here it would become very
one-dimensional and it would become all
about whether white can attack which
takes a long long time actually but uh
that's i think the question in the
current position is ariane gonna open
things up kind of make things spicy put
gary under pressure by pushing upon two
squares forward next move or is he just
going to take a slow strategic approach
it feels like terry is the one with the
kind of next card up his sleeve and
anish knows that something's coming he
just has to be ready for it and how
interesting that that one pawn moving it
two squares or one square is the big
difference in the game yeah massive
difference wow
i have a feeling it's he's going to try
and push it two squares just because
he's slightly more dynamic um at least
an instinct uh arientari but
we'll see gary
slightly low on the clock as well
i don't think his opening experiment has
been a success i think uh i wasn't sure
earlier but ivanka might be right this
choice of opening
not the best not yeah objectively not
the most ambitious but also
stylistically just not suiting gary
he definitely doesn't look comfortable
at the moment all right well all the
quarterfinal matches they are in game
once and this is a day with shotgun
start so
as soon as they finish the game they
will have 15 minutes until game two
starts so it's going to be
chess going on at all times today it's a
very fun day in
the meltwater champions chess tour and
uh the bar and all of the games
i mean roughly to the center but in the
game one between magnus carlsen and dave
danton definitely looks like the world
champion has an advantage with the white
pieces
yeah and anish playing a preparatory
move i would say it actually
appealed to me and it came to me when
david was showing out his lines you know
that uh after should ariane play the
pawn break in the center you know
there is something if a knight appears
on the e5 square it would be on the same
diagonal as the queen so this kind of
gives some possibility for the queen
just to
dodge the attack and step one move to
the right yeah let's just show this
we might see it it's gone for it yep so
when the pawn steps forward after a
trade anisha's idea is to pin this black
knight
sorry sorry um yeah so it looks like
this is about to happen so the black
knight doesn't have time to go and
remove this white bishop because if it
does then the black queen is actually
loose and hanging
so it would drop off the board um so
this is indeed the current position
jovanka called it and now i'm expecting
this queen to either move or be defended
um you can defend it with the black rook
by coming bringing it across defending
the queen or you can maybe move her and
maybe eye up this pawn this however can
be blocked remember this key square that
we uh we talked about a while ago it is
eternally whites to occupy and white can
use his bishop and because it's
protected by a pawn it's an outpost and
it does actually block out this black
queen from the game it's quite risky um
aryan playing like this uh positionally
wise because uh he's changed the pawn
structure aryan and he's changed it to
the detriment of his position his
position structurally has become worse
because of the the pawn here highlighted
in the middle that cannot be defended by
another pawn i think we mentioned this
it's like you know pawnee no mates isn't
it this one it hasn't got any of his
mates next to it to defend it so it's
always going to be a target of pawnee no
mates in the middle it's the deep one
simon david no mates
david orrs has mates wherever david is
so it's there but it you know it is
quite risky because
if black doesn't keep the activity up
he's just made his structure worse and
he's opened up the bishops for white as
well so i i don't know if you think i'm
like
with you i agree with you totally there
simon i mean
my
oh
it's like bad experiences all over again
so my my terrible experiences all from
this white side of this particular
opening all came about when black simply
waited they waited in those type of
positions with all the minor pieces on
and they just said what you're going to
do what are you going to do when i come
for you and i was like um i don't know
so you have a music challenge
now
you know there's one thing about me kyle
that you're in all in a secret there's
always some song or some theme tune
happening in my mind it's just lyrics
yeah i wake up in the morning and i have
a tune in my head and someone once said
to me i think it was your friend
daughtbian who said maybe you should
have been a musician
another life and i'm like well maybe
yeah well chess and music there are
comparisons
to those and uh the knight has moved
yeah back where it came from though uh
harrion's queen now i don't like the
positioning of the black queen we
mentioned that the white bishop just
kind of locks it out of the game and the
black knight it sat on the square a few
moves ago i understand it's gone and
done a job it's one two uh it's when to
capture a pawn it's come back now but
it feels like it's time for white's rook
white's remaining rope next to his king
to just centralize occupy an open line
i'm not really sure black's next move
unless black wants to push his pawn in
the center of the board but that also
comes with risk black's isolated pawn
maybe it will push forward maybe that's
ariane's big plan but
yeah the white bishop's looking pretty
good now yeah i mean
playing this break that black's played
you should really have a plan in mind
and if the plan is just to
remove pawns from the board and make
your opponents bishops stronger it seems
rather strange and
this could be like you know ariane is is
the younger player he's very good
actively but again it could just be a
sign of a weakness in his game maybe i'd
have been very tempted to do the same i
probably would have done the same
because i'd like active play but it can
often backfire and i think uh maybe a
bit of maybe a bit of maturity there has
just just been shown that
holding the position uh i think would
have been a safer option at least here i
just fear i fear for black a little bit
here in the long run
and why is that why what is the main
weakness in that black people yeah well
it's the pawn in the middle so it's old
uh davey no mates or whatever he is uh
and in the middle and uh
and there we go so white is now lining
up against that pawn so that pawn is
going to be under some pressure you just
can't defend it with another pawn the
way the structure is and if you ever
push that pawn forwards which maybe we
can show um you know just if we simply
take that pawn off
and let's say the knight comes in the
bishop moves to c4
you look at this position and suddenly
well who's got the two bishops white's
got the two bishops and bishops work in
positions where there's no pawns because
there's no pawns to block them in
i know the black knight is very strong
at the moment but in general rule is
bishops are just very good in open
positions and
that's that's the way this game is going
giving giving white some advantage i
feel uh in in the position so this is
this is where i just fear a little bit
we have another move though on that
doesn't look good to me yeah this last
move yeah knights on the rim are very
dim normally and uh i guess there's a
specific idea yes you're attacking this
bishop oh your instincts are right there
the computer hates this move as well the
evaluation bar hates this move um so the
idea is you're attacking this white
bishop and for example if it runs away
because you want to keep your bishops
intact if it runs away somewhere for
example then the black queen is open to
go and capture a pawn um so
sorry i i've cheated okay i don't
normally cheat but occasionally i do
when i'm feeling lazy
so i'm having a little cheaty moment and
i've just looked at the computer and
there is a move here which is extremely
strong for white but maybe only one move
which will give white a very nice very
nice position my first instinct was
maybe push this pawn forward guard this
bishop but now you said there's
something yeah bigger it must be to do
with okay bring this bishop in maybe
ah you know it doesn't it doesn't take
you long david
i don't think i would have seen this
actually if you hadn't given me that
hint i saw it but i just thought the
rook moves to the left and yeah but i
think guess what
he's played it i think you can just take
the pawn in the middle mate oh then you
another drops but yes yes
for example here the black queen can
also swing across white has two
undefended pieces you have to be a bit
careful but uh what is the idea can
white's bishops continue chasing the
black rocks maybe maybe this is it maybe
the other bishop comes in look at this
look at these bishops now we talked
about long-range pieces how they're fine
on their starting squares these bishops
are anything but on their starting
squares
controlling nearly every escape square
for this black rook this black rock only
has one safe square right yes i mean
those bishops are actually fantastic
aren't they with a rook and this is kind
of the danger we were mentioning that
you open up the bishops they they come
to play and next move maybe now you
capture this weak pawn in the center of
the board and you defend your bishop in
the process what can black even move
here that's good queen so oh sorry he
can take the porn is what i wanted to
say oh okay it gets complicated queen
then
your rook is hanging yeah
because he's hanging there's rooks
everywhere going on yeah i mean look at
this queen takes rook queen takes rook
and it's been a trade it's level
material but surely white's doing well
with these three dominant pieces
actually how many pieces are on the
seventh round
there's a fair few there aren't they see
okay but he didn't play it he didn't
play it so he's played the
more sort of uh
obvious move i'd say but he took this
pawn but i got that bishop move was
looking really strong you found there
david actually really good move so
what's the answer you know should black
swing the queen to the e6 square and
attack the rook and the bishop double
attack i guess it's his idea to bring
his queen in and offer a trade here
maybe
it feels a bit loose i don't like having
this white king on a back rank with no
escape squares it feels like you've got
to be really careful for example rook
takes rook and it looks like you're
about to get checkmated and this would
indeed be checkmate but the white bishop
can ride to the rescue this bishop can
slide back and block the check so maybe
it's just about okay for any gary and he
still has these great pieces like bones
in the throat for black deep in the
black camp
so it's probably still good but
i prefer keeping the bishops and in the
current position there's actually
options for
tarry he can also remove this bishop
with his knight
your move looks a lot stronger david
just keeping the bishops and they
actually control so many squares on
those strange
placements so and and you'd leave that
black knight on that stupid square as
well
why allow black to exchange off that
really really weird night there i think
if anish had more than two and a half
minutes he probably would have played
this move and kind of established these
two monster bishops
are you a little bit worried for
anisha's time
slightly although the position is maybe
turning in his favor it's definitely
black on the uh defensive here i think
ariel the onus is on him to try and
equalize this game and try and hold
and uh and do you think now the key for
aryan is then to find a move that
prevents a niche from moving that bishop
to that fantastic square he has a few he
has a few options you know he has to
first of all calculate the
any the
attacks and of course the captures and i
do quite like the knight takes bishop
that you mentioned
and i don't know it's such a fiery
position it's quite this is the thing
isn't it you vancouver you get these you
get these kind of i said it boring
opening but nearly every boring opening
becomes they just come to life so it
doesn't really matter how you play the
opening sometimes i mean exchange
frenches you know they're supposed to be
the most boring opening ever but they
often become so tactical and and it's
going the way that you were mentioned
here david yeah
that's the thing if you've got two
exciting players give them a boring
position they'll liven it up they'll
find a way definitely exactly and uh
humanity rules um and why did
why did anish take with his rook and not
porn here good question i think he
wanted to firstly gain time the white
rook was attacking the black queen so
you kind of force your opponent's move i
think it's every chess player's instinct
to make sure your opponent only has one
logical option or you don't want to give
them four or five
good options also i guess if the white
pawn had recaptured and stood where the
white rook currently stands then white
would have doubled pawns on the b file
and so it's strategic uh strategic stuff
and uh rook takes pawn for black is
still in the air right
big threat it is big threat right
so
i was thinking of queen e3 i just want
to simplify like um that's yeah
maybe maybe there's other moves here try
and get the queens off the board because
if you don't i mean for example if you
get greedy your bishop's under fire for
example if you take this black pawn uh
white is two pawns up temporarily but we
talked about the king a few move uh a
few moves ago and as ivanka mentioned
rook takes pawn is potentially on the
board it's very complicated actually
white does have some counter checks
against the black king whose king is
weaker but the idea for example just to
show would be after rotates rook
suddenly the white king is indeed
trapped background checkmate as we call
it
so
it's so complicated can white get away
with taking this pawn for example rook
takes porn and meeting this move with a
check protected by its queen uh or is he
going to take the safe option as simon
mentioned and i know which one i would
choose if i didn't have much time on the
clock gary now under one minute i would
definitely choose to try and trade
queens um probably in this manner as
well just get the queens off the board
white is temporarily one pawn up and
another pawn about to fall
so getting the queens off the board i
think is definitely the safest option um
i'm still trying to calculate this one
myself uh rook takes pawn but i don't
think giri should waste too much more
time thinking about a pawn grab don't be
greedy when you have 30 seconds on your
clock keep things safe get the queens
off the board yeah
and uh that's his style as well
oh he drops his bishop back that should
be good right it
prevents any uh rook takes pawn or
bishop takes pawn ideas yup it blocks
this line for the black rook let's go
back to the players because it's really
heating up gary on 38 seconds
three minutes down on the clock but he
has one extra pawn on the board so uh
ariane's still on the board at least
he's the one fighting for the draw and
you also mentioned the the white king it
doesn't have any lift i guess
is that still a problem does he need to
move one of those pawns yes yes
very good but this is a good start
today
into a tournament right now definitely
like
under six i have i've had so many
comments from people watching the show
and they're saying we're they're super
impressed by your standard like to begin
with they were like we don't think kai
knows how he knows too much yeah and
then suddenly every single show she gets
better you get better and better and
better and now you're like oh back crank
mate i think you could beat magnus
so like it's h7 i have uh in the app
yeah yeah i'm at like eight years old
okay but i'm struggling on eight years
old he was already good at eight years
old magnus so
hard at that one
meanwhile yeah i think you're completely
right kai if anish gets one move if
tarry does nothing here wastes a move
then white's h pawn will just step
forward one square maybe two squares
give the white king an escape route
so that's why terry has to do something
quickly he has to try and
seize the moment utilize the fact that
the white king is a tactical weakness
and i don't see it though at the moment
i must confess the white rook and white
bishop on the fifth rank they're pretty
stable for now
it's hard to kick them away
and if you can't keep them away how are
blacks rooks getting into the game
yeah maybe the evaluation by saying plus
one for white that means white does have
one safe extra point and okay this rook
lift
is met by an offer of a queen trade very
logical your idea simon can play now
yeah it looks pretty good for white
doesn't it i mean a safe pawn probably
here um
all of white's pieces are well placed
and okay ariel says no thank you i'm not
trading off queens but now kaia's idea
comes into force look at that the king
has got some lift yeah
feels nice
and as soon as that move is played the
evaluation bar shoots up for white kate
shoots back down slightly but
yeah it's looking very one-sided right
now and
when in doubt push the h-porches harry
harry oh we had this awesome entry into
our quiz of the day
it is about harry
um
but i'll i'll read it at a less
critical critical time yeah it is a
critical moment and we did see black
push upon two squares forward and rather
than the uh kind of allow the advance of
harry
white has done the same white is just
locked down the whole king side now no
real pawn breaks on this right half of
the board play will switch back to the
other flank
oh i'm trying to stifle sneeze yep oh
dear tongue yep
thanks
guys we had that tweet like a year ago
someone's saying if you want a selfless
niece then you'd put your tongue
all the way up and you're really in your
mouth right yeah i think i'm just so
full of nervous tension watch the game
yeah and the bar now it definitely goes
up for a niche after this move by ariane
yeah i understand what aaron is trying
to do he's trying to put pressure on
white's bishop he's trying to kick away
the white bishop because then the black
rooks will be great but i don't really
see the immediate threat
maybe he wants to push a pawn to kick
away the swipe bishop even under 20
seconds though i mean this is this is
the one hope that aryan's got there
anisha's very short time and the queens
are still on the board making it how did
he make that move his hands were on his
head oh wow levitation he did this
yesterday as well
he's he he's in a primo if he took a
while jedi master actually i want to see
that again
[Music]
what other parts of his body could he be
using
[Laughter]
it must have been a premo but uh maybe
technical stuff was a little late maybe
there's a lag or maybe his webcam froze
just for a few seconds maybe that's true
yeah that's the only explanation i can
come up with will it happen again okay
his hands are on his head he's got under
20 seconds let's let's uh or watch anish
giri and he did it again
what's that pre-move that's twice in a
row isn't it i i don't know that's not
approved that's not a pre-move because
black could have played anything and
this was not a safe pre-move uh how is
he doing this is that the magician
he is clearly the jedi yeah he's like
you know he's the force he's voice
activated he could be just like
telekinetic kind of he's going to be
kind of like the i mean the mouth skill
that's very important right you need to
actually use the mouse yeah and it
probably wouldn't be a good idea i
must be the webcam
it's the hands down maybe there's just a
delay with the camera i mean i i think
that's the
that is
very strange yeah yeah and uh ariane
down to 40 seconds on the clock
but i have to say anish's move was
slightly mysterious to me yeah i think
safety first i think it's good kind of
speed chess tactics
kind of good strategy when you're low on
the clock just protect everything
white's rook now on a safe square and
anish uh wait sorry ariane there he was
just kind of gesturing is that a mouse
slip that must be a mouse lip he was
shaking his head really
was there i
i don't know what black's rook move was
doing simply black's rook on a terrible
square now and yeah might be trade would
end the game almost yeah i'm sure he was
going to move that rook and attack the
queen but now anish has offered a queen
trade and it's quite
a powerful move actually because you're
gonna have to you're hurry down to two
seconds oh he made that move with a few
seconds left and queen's coming off the
board that is going to signal at the end
now and another pawn is going to drop
actually after the queen takes queen oh
no you can you don't have to well maybe
you can't you can take the pawn you can
just grab it yeah there we go two pawns
up now for initiary yeah it's just a
mopping up job now he just needs to keep
everything nice and safe and protected
he has no weaknesses though gary nothing
for terry to attack
yeah the white bishop drops back look
how everything is protected in white's
camp literally every single pawn every
single piece is protected
maybe his strategy just worked perfectly
in this game uh i mean you know he
wasn't going for an open advantage he
was basically thinking i'm going to wait
until arianne does something and as soon
as he did something the position just
went got worse and worse didn't it so it
kind of worked perfectly obviously
they've worked together they know each
other well so anisha's like you say
psychologically outwitting aryan saying
hey i know that you have a tendency to
be impatient and to want to do things
and okay harian simply retreating the
bishop
it's it's difficult to suggest a move
actually for him he just has to wait and
see what anish
comes up with max pieces aren't even
active so when your two pawns down in an
end game sometimes you get compensation
by throwing your pieces forward
attacking weaknesses forcing your
opponent on the defensive but that's not
even the case here terry is too clear
pawns down and if all the rooks come off
the board game over if white's pawns
push forward game over
terry yeah out of ideas and it's just
all about anish's experience he used it
really well in those critical moments
when to trade queens off when to defend
everything and i think this is a model
game actually how to handle uh
complicated positions when you're low on
time you did it perfectly there's no
tricks here either i mean this is this
is the only thing that black tried to do
something on the king side um you know
but i love what white's doing here
swapping pieces off when your two pawns
up try to swap things off and uh this is
why black's kept the rook on the board
going for a potential pawn push to
create some openings in the position but
it's not really going to work out yeah
unfortunately
even even maybe
bishop here yeah swap some more pieces
off winning style simon yeah that's a
nice tactic yeah and uh we say okay it
has happened white has given up a rook
for a bishop but white's bishop is going
to enter the center of the board if the
black rook moves away white sriracha
goes to the corner and checkmate's the
black king and there we go i think
ariane terry he has resigned
about to lose even more material
it's over
and just